attention interpellation manifestation
les émotions étaient fortes ce samedi
1er mai les manifestants ont fait
entendre leur voix sur les plus grandes
rues et places de la capitale
boulevard voltaire à paris des esprits
se sont notamment et chauffée avec la
venue d'un groupuscule de black blocks
mais les gilets jaunes et syndicats ont
tenu tout au long de la journée a
rappelé l'importance de la fête
nationale du travail le 1er mai c'est
quand même la fête des travailleurs et
que faut rappeler à ceux qui n'ont
toujours pas compris que l'ensemble des
gilets jaunes sont des travailleurs
aujourd'hui invisible qui gagne peu et
qui ont du mal à boucler les fins de
mois dont il était légitime qu'on puisse
être aujourd'hui dans cette
manifestation est de pouvoir être
visible montré que les gilet jaune sont
des travailleurs et de rejoindre cette
belle fête du travail avec l'ensemble
des manifestations un peu partout en
france
non ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment la
solidarité l'égalité et la justice
sociale la justice sociale parce que là
on en est loin c'est encore les très
riches qui continuent à un gouffre et
d'aider des bénéfices et des profits au
détriment des plus pauvres
ce n'est qu'un début nous on souhaite
que ça soit vraiment la mort ce dédain
printemps de luttes d'un printemps
social de lutte important effort une
journée de mobilisation à laquelle ont
répondu la cgt fo la fsu solidaires et
des organisations de jeunesse
u 9 et u n l lutte ouvrière gloire au
prolétariat lyon renfilé son habit de
contestataires avec des images
impressionnantes
[Musique]
trois mille manifestants et un climat
plus que tendu en tête de cortège
selon le progrès et la préfecture du
rhône les forces de l'ordre ont dû faire
face à des tirs de mortiers et les
bombes agricoles 27 policiers et
gendarmes ont été blessés
ces derniers répondant parfois aussi
avec dureté une pluie fine et une
ambiance plus festive à marseille
le personnel hospitalier ou encore
sympathisants de la cause écologique ont
répondu présent vers l'avant mais vers
autre chose
l'une est d'abord l'espoir d'une vie
meilleure tous les corps de métiers
représentés également dans la ville rose
selon la préfecture de toulouse 3700
personnes sont descendues dans les rues
un cortège animé par les intermittents
du spectacle qui occupent depuis plus
d'un mois le théâtre de la cité pour
dénoncer la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
les revendications que nous portons
aujourd'hui ce sont des revendications
de justice de liberté d'égalité
par exemple le salaire qu'ils soient sur
la base d'un smic à 2000 euros parce que
c'est ce dont on a besoin pour vivre
aujourd'hui au minimum des
revendications fortes aussi partagé par
jean-luc mélenchon ted affiche du 1er
mai lillois
côté gouvernement la ministre du travail
a condamné très fermement les casseurs
qui ont volé cette journée aux
organisations syndicales selon les moore
et d'elisabeth board